constituée en intersyndicale les
délégués entrée ce matin nouvelle froid
en négociation à la demande de la
direction au siège de la poste boulevard
pasteur à fort de france
fort de leur plate forme revendicative
il espère obtenir satisfaction
nous attendions certaines garanties que
nous avons reçu hier soir tard à savoir
la venue de la directrice exécutive de
l'outre-mer en fin de semaine et la
possibilité de négocier avec la ligne
managériale et en mandat pour pouvoir
valider toutes les décisions qui seront
prises à l'issue de ces négociations
en parallèle à cette rencontre et comme
stipulé dans l' ordonnance du juge des
référés
c'est les accès des différents sites de
la poste sont libres en revanche le
piquet de grève est maintenue aux abords
du centre de tri de dillon après quinze
jours de fermeture
les clients sont enfin soulagé mon colis
depuis le 5 décembre
finalement c'est aujourd'hui oui enfin
soulagé ça m'a aidé pour le travail
c'est pourtant vous allez enfin ça
fonctionne il n'y a pas tout le monde
mais bon c'est au moins
on peut récupérer calme et poli
aujourd'hui si certains distributeurs de
billets sont approvisionnés cela impose
tout de même un parcours du combattant
oui c'est un soulagement parce que
partout ils m'ont dit des les automates
y sont fermées il ne délivre plus
d'argent alors je reviens de l'évêché
j'ai dit je passe un petit je fais un
petit tour ici pour voir si vraiment je
peux enlever un petit peu d'argent
aujourd'hui je suis soulagé parce que la
semaine dernière j'ai fait
ici j'ai fait la montée et j'ai pété au
sein ville il pas trouvé d'argent il ya
les guichets étaient comme ça
indisponibles ça fonctionne mais tu ne
peux pas faire d'un transfert on peut
rien faire
en fait on peut faire aucune opération
peut avoir de l'argent mais après si tu
veux faire une opération peut pas fait
en opération la passerelle média affiche
en laye la porte la totalité au 22 mai
mais ça va obliger vous ai dit chara bon
là je compte gouttes
ils partiront trois son idée ça le bon
fonctionnement des différents services
de la poste dépend donc uniquement de
ces nouvelles négociations engagées ce
matin entre les syndicats et les cadres
de direction